- I think, it has to be probably
when I was in eighth grade.
A girl in my class told me
I was one of the two
ugliest boys in the school.
That's been
well over 40 years since
I was in eighth grade.
And to be carrying it still now
into the fifth decade is crazy.
Any time I think I might be
dressed well or look good,
that does come back and haunt me
and just says, well,
you're one of the two
ugliest boys in our class.
- I guess, I was stupid.
Yeah, just homework.
Homework and little things
like dropping glass.
Me and my dad,
don't really have that good
of relationship right now,
because of the way he's talked
to me when I was little.
But I was stuck feeling
stupid for a long time.
I feel like I was like playing myself down
for a lot of situations,
because what my dad
said to me in the past.
So, it's just like, I don't know. Yeah.
- Okay.
So, the most painful thing I've been told
was by my mother
when she essentially blamed
me for my grandmother's death.
We were traveling, my
grandmother's sick at home,
and then she told me, because
I had said a swear word,
it was just damn, the word was damn.
And then, the next day, my
grandmother had passed away.
She's like, "Because you said that,
your grandmother passed away."
I still hold that against her to this day.
I can't see my mom the
same because of that.
And I hold incredible guilt
surrounding my grandmother's death.
- [Thoraya] Do you think you'll ever
find healing from it?
- No. I would have to like...
Unless my grandmother could
come back from the dead herself
to tell me like, it's not your fault,
I don't think I could ever get over it.
- So, when I was a child,
I had a really,
it was a very violent childhood.
And when I was
about 18 years old,
I got kicked out of my mom's house
and one of the things that she told me
was to get the (censored)
out of her house.
And she called me a piece of (censored)
I held onto that for
the last 15 years almost.
I've stemmed in all kinds of
things, abandonment issues,
thinking that I was a piece of (censored)
And essentially, letting
that mold a huge part
of who I had become in my early 20s
and basically until
recently, to be honest.
So, yeah, I think, that
was the hardest thing
that I've ever heard
was from my own mother.
- It was my mom telling me,
"How could I ever be proud of you?"
When I came out to her.
And that always sticks in my
psyche (laughs) that
just not being able to like,
my mom asking me,
"How could I ever be proud of
you when you're not straight?"
Whatever. So, yeah.
- It was, I think, my
dad was really mad at me
and he was mocking me,
because a year earlier,
I tried to kill myself
and he was making fun of that.
He said,
"Oh at least I'm not the kid
that tried to kill himself."
- Your dad ain't never cared about you
and he don't give a (censored) about you.
I just started talking back to my dad now.
Things have been good.
When I speak to him now though,
he'd be the only one that
seemed like listen for real.
And it's like you live in a world
where everybody has their own perspective
and nobody wants to get
to know anybody else's.
But when I talk to him, I feel that.
And he give me that idea
that he really do care
about what I gotta think about
and that we not so different.
And it's crazier too,
'cause me and my dad got the same name,
so it make me feel
like I do got somebody on
this earth that understand me.
- The most painful thing I was told
was when my dad woke me up
and told me that my nana had passed away.
Yeah. (chuckles)
Every day, I find moments where I'm like,
oh, I wish I could just call her
or let her know what's new in my life.
I very much leaned on her when I was
younger.
My mom worked a lot.
She was a young mom,
so she took care of us for the most part.
I would just say she embodied sunshine.
Any room she walked in, if
it was dark, it was light.
She had this laugh that anytime
you would hear it, was
like a cackle. (laughs)
It was annoying a little bit,
but really, really funny.
And you couldn't help, but laugh as well.
She's just very special.
Thank you for asking.
It feels good to open up a little bit,
'cause I don't talk about it often,
but I don't know,
sharing just a part of her in
my day feels good. (chuckles)
So, thank you.
- Yeah.
What was your name?
- Cheryl.
- Okay.
- My name is Cheryl.
Cheryl too. (chuckles)
- The first thing comes
from my mind is when
someone I know told me that
my brother is better than me
and a lot of stuff.
When I'm with my brother, I
feel like I'm not there at all.
- [Thoraya] When you're with your brother,
- Uh-huh.
- with a lot of people,
you don't show your personality?
- Yeah, because my brother
is like show up to everyone
- Mm.
- and I'm like in the back.
And the most painful thing
was when I enter to a room
and someone says like,
where's your brother?
And you, why are you
here? Something like that.
And that was like a
shock to me. (chuckles)
He doesn't know that I feel
like I can't show me when I'm with him.
- [Thoraya] You've never told him?
- No, no.
- [Thoraya] Does the way you feel
and the things you were told,
- Mm-hmm, mm-hmm.
- [Thoraya] does it change how you feel
about your brother at all?
- Five years ago, yes. Now, no.
I go to therapy, so I
can change that feeling,
because it was a very bad feeling,
because my brother
doesn't have that fault.
- Mm-hmm.
- That what I...
I was free. So, no, no, no, no, no.
I love him. (chuckles) Yeah.
- Oh, the first time someone told me
me and my sister didn't
look alike, I guess.
'cause that's my favorite
person in the entire world.
So, telling us that we
didn't look alike was harsh.
Like my own blood, my own
person was not looking like me.
We didn't act alike at the
time. So, it was weird.
It hurt a lot. (laughs)
(interviewee chuckles)
They're my favorite person
on this entire planet.
(piano music)
- I think, in my first relationship,
I was told things like,
"God, you can't really do
anything by yourself, can you?"
Or like, "How would you
survive without me?"
Just really demeaning things
that made me feel like I
couldn't be my own person.
So, it really sunk into me for a long time
that I couldn't be by myself
and I couldn't be my own person
and I needed someone to help
me with everything in my life.
And I knew deep down
that that wasn't true,
because I'd always been
very independent as a kid,
but that person just sucked
my entire soul into theirs
and devoured it and spit it back out.
And it took a long time to unlearn that
and realize that that's not true.
And that was their insecurity
of knowing that if I realized
that I could do anything
myself, I would leave.
Now, I live fully nomadically in my van.
I've been doing it for three years
and it's been my dream since
before I met that person.
And I do everything by myself,
and I feel like completely
confident in that fact.
And it's a really beautiful
circle moment, full circle moment.
- So, I've been complimented a lot.
This is a compliment,
but it's painful to me that
I'm such a very good listener
and that I listen to people well.
But I take it as a painful thing to hear,
because I feel like I don't
share my feelings enough
and I'm very...
I don't speak a lot to other people,
and so I feel like people never hear me.
So, I feel like when I speak,
they don't listen as much as I do.
- Because of my situation,
I can't really travel.
So, when my family travels out,
they express to me that they
have to disconnect from me,
forget that I'm here so
they can enjoy themselves.
- I think, the most
painful is just being told
you're too sensitive.
And it hurts because it's the very thing
that a sensitive person
would not wanna be told.
It makes them feel like
they're not enough,
they'll never be enough.
No one will ever understand that.
- Mm. Okay.
I think, the most painful
thing I've been told
is that I might never know
what this is all about.
Yeah. That this life might
always be a mystery, for sure.
- [Thoraya] Wait, before you go,
have you gotten any answers
as you're going older?
- Just opinions and none
of 'em are really answers,
'cause no one really knows.
- [Thoraya] What do you believe?
- Take your time and
enjoy the little things.
- The most painful thing I've been told
was something I was told
that I didn't even realize I was told,
which is I was 45 and I got
diagnosed with bipolar disorder.
I lived my whole life,
two children, a wife, the house,
San Diego, beautiful, everything great.
And then, I lost it.
I lived on the street, I
lived on the street in Mexico.
I went to jail five times in Mexico.
And then, because of my sister,
the only one that saved me.
She saved me
and brought me in and
I'm living in her place.
- [Thoraya] What was the
most hurtful part of it all?
- Oh, my kids.
I was
the go-to.
The wife owned an advertising agency.
She's lovely, she's
awesome, but she's a worker.
I worked from home and I had the kids.
And they were my babies and
I just disappeared on 'em.
And I was, every day at school,
everything, every soccer,
doing gymnastics in the
backyard, everything.
And then, I was gone and
there was a babysitter
and boy, let me tell you,
that didn't help them at all.
That was hardest thing, the hardest.
I'm still feeling the effects.
I just wanna say that I'm
in touch with my daughter
- Mm-hmm.
- all the time,
and we're starting to patch up.
And I see my son three times a week.
And I'm working on a product now,
a golf product that I hope saves me.
And it was a golf product
that me and my dad worked on
and we worked on it together together.
And then, he died and I
bailed out on it, of course.
But now, I'm back.
So, I feel like it's a gift
from my dad who is in heaven.
What the product does
that nothing else does
is it provides a clubface angle
visibility,
and it says if you're clubface
and your putter path both
are square and on line,
it uses a fused color,
a blue color over a yellow
color that makes it green.
And when it's green, you know it's good.
I am selling it on fuzion.golf.
It's ready to go right now.
- [Thoraya] Okay, it'll be linked
in the description for my listeners.
Check it out.
- Oh.
- There you go.
Thank you so much.
- Any golfers out there?
It works, I promise.
Really good. Really, you'll be happy.
(piano music)
- Hey, everyone, for
those of you who are new,
my name is Thoraya and I'm
the girl behind the camera.
Make sure to subscribe and
hit the notification bell,
so you'll be notified every
time I have a new episode up.
And follow me on Instagram,
I'll be posting more on there.
As always, thank you guys for everything.
I love you all and I'll see you next time.
(piano music)